so naturally I have to talk about
climate change you're a big denier my
mistake maybe I'll switch over that may
be a big payday in that I can really
cash out yeah let's get some headlines
here all right so climate change I can't
believe that in 2015 still when you
watch cable news and whenever they're
talking about climate change they still
bring on two people to debate it as if
it's in a debate you know it's not a
debate the scientific community give me
a percentage here what is it something
like 91% of science in 97 percentage the
number that I've heard okay so 97% I'm
not a mathematician but that's a pretty
high percentage yet they still have
these people debating what what do you
think's going on there we'll talk about
the media part in a sec but just in
terms of how people can deny something
that science is consistently proving
there's a lack of understanding there's
people just dug in there's several
lawmakers I think don't believe it
anymore who still say that they're
deniers but they're really not but we
just don't know how to break them out of
jail together yeah break them out one at
a time they'll be shocked by the prison
guards so like they're all held hostage
by their constituent holding ostrich
fire and their beliefs that they're dug
in they don't know how to that needs to
be a jailbreak through you break all
seven or nine of them out together yeah
we got to figure out how to get them all
out so they can just you know there'd be
safety in numbers if you could do that
yeah I don't think they all believe it
and they can't you can't believe it
anymore there's just enough very good
science scientific clues as to the fact
it's not only happening but man is the
number one culprit you add more co2 to
the atmosphere it warms up the planet
it's always done that and we have much
more co2 than we've ever had so to not
to deny that that's happening and have
all this stuff about it you know what's
happening on Mars and all this stuff
it's all background noise yeah it's
really good science people say well
Galileo was a rogue and he had a
different theory and he was persecuted
you're persecuting us no Galileo had
science he saw he got a telescope
primitive by today's standards but
looked over the holy Christ there's
ganymedian IO and Callisto and Europa
and they're going around Jupiter I can
see it there are different positions
they're clearly moving
around Jupiter where I can see
Copernicus and Galileo use science and
so to to use that we embrace this denial
at our own peril yeah and right now
whatever we do now it is my opinion that
there will be great damage done to like
the Marshall Islands in South Florida
what have you that's in the pipeline the
time to stop that was back in the 90s
yeah we had taken the action that was
recommended and pleaded for and begged
for the perhaps we could have done
something with that but now we're 2015
people are still debating it and they're
not willing there's a lot of money
obviously in fossil fuels still and the
people who have interest in fossil fuels
want to squeeze the last dollar out and
people kid themselves I don't think
everybody goes I don't care that I'm
ruining the planet I'm gonna do this and
I don't think a lot of people even think
that I think I've heard some people are
in denial like the alcoholic and denial
yeah I think no I'm not doing anything
with to make climate change they're
wrong about that and I need to keep
people warm and healthy and
what-have-you and transport goods and
services around I'm doing a good thing
and people lie to themselves about stuff
it's like an alcoholic we're all
alcoholics on oil we really are yeah I
saw the alcohol it goes it's that damn
boss of mine that caused me that problem
he was such a bastard that's why I got
fired and that [ __ ] of a wife the
reason I got a divorce is because and
that cop that was a crazy badge heavy
cop - it was a cop it was the wife it
was the boss it's never yourself and
we're the addicts like that right we
want to deny that it's that it's fossil
fuels that's doing this because it's
such a wonderful thing I ride my bike up
Laurel Canyon to Mulholland regularly
and it takes a lot of work David you
know if you can just do this and get to
the top of Mulholland that's all the
effort I did yeah this not pedaling up
for 20 minutes up at the top and Bohol
it just went like that and I get up to
the top of Moho and it's like what a
miracle and to allowed your fields used
to get the ox and you have animals to
help you with the work and get a knock a
team of oxen and go through the fields
and hang on the thing yourself like this
and it was a lot of work to tell a feel
by hand is tremendous work suddenly they
got these contraptions that will tell it
for you mm-hmm a machine this goes to
what we were talking about how far
we are from our food and how easily we
can get everything and the phones that
were well it's all sort of interlaced
and sort of takes the responsibility
away from us in so many ways yeah it's a
free lunch that we thought would go on
forever and never had a price tag you
know nobody ever thought there would be
something like climate change there was
a brief a very brief theory from the
scientific community in the 60s about
global cooling yeah it didn't get much
play because it didn't really make any
sense you know but it lasted about a
year or two all it made was a cover of
popular science magazine it didn't
really make peer-reviewed studies like
it has like global warming has but it
lasted a while people have been in
denial about it a long time and then
when James Hansen started to testify at
the guy from NASA in the 80s a lot of
the scientific community indeed people
who were had embraced a global cooling
thing briefly they were like wait a
minute this makes more sense let me look
at the numbers then they looked at the
numbers and one by one they were
convinced there's very few people left
who think it's not happening scientists
to think it's not happening consider it
in the medical community though David
you go to a doctor he says it and you
got a problem you have cancer you got to
get chemo radiation or something right
away thank you go to another doctor Edie
you have cancer you have you need chemo
radiation or something some treatment
like that right away I'm gonna go the
last three doctors tell you you're fine
you're gonna go with the last three
you're gonna go with a 97 who told you
of the more you need cancer treatment
right and you can't say well I don't
believe in cancer to us it doesn't exist
you can say it well you Carol right you
could say it at your own peril and
that's where we're at now
so what would you say to all the people
cuz this is one of the things I hear a
lot from Republicans they'll say well
America what we put out there now it's
unfair for us to say it's other
countries because we've been through our
industrial revolution already right so
we can't tell India too what to do right
now or a lot of you know places in that
part of the world we can't tell them
they have to do it because they're going
through what we did you know you mean
like so that there's this sort of
self-importance here we have to help
those other countries leapfrog over that
old technology we built our Brooklyn
Bridge and Empire State Building with
high sulfur coal and steel mills you
know
in Pittsburgh polluting the air that's
what we did we did that no you don't
have to do that again I remember kind of
waking up to the idea of leapfrogging
over old technology back in the 90s I
went to Australia and in Australia in
the 90s everybody had a cell phone
homeless people had cell phones there
was somehow very cheap there with the
way they put up the repeaters and
everything quickly they had subsidies
for him I don't know what they had it
because they leapfrogged over the whole
thing there's there's such a vast
country and they certainly had phone
lines in Australia but the idea of
stringing new lines everywhere and
getting telephone lines all throughout
the outback in every part of Australia
no cell repeaters they leapfrogged over
the old technology we have to help them
do that with solar the people in these
poor villages they need light in their
Hut right now because they're knocking
over kerosene lamps and getting burned
and they're carrying kerosene great
distances carrying you know firewood
taking down the last tree you know
carrying firewood great distances we can
help them with solar panels and solar
ovens you leapfrog over the old
technology yeah and now that didn't work
for everything in places like China who
want to manufacture all sorts of goods
and what-have-you you have to do other
things but they're realizing the problem
now in Beijing because of the LAT the
lost productivity from the air pollution
there yeah we've done stories on that
town I forget the name of the town with
the smog so polluted yeah it's just
beyond imagination and they're starting
to see the unfortunate side effect of it
it's not just that people were unhappy
they're losing productivity why didn't
you show up for work again today I was
in the hospital I was in the pulmonary
clinic yeah I couldn't breathe
I have emphysema I have cancer I'm dying
of cancer from the pollution that's why
I missed work I'm very sorry yeah so
maybe that's what I'll get them because
they do love productivity so eventually
if the productivity really starts going
down maybe that then causes some wounds
they're putting they're putting up
plenty of coal plants I'm not suggesting
they aren't but they're putting up many
many more solar manufacturing plants
than we are yeah they're really doubling
down on on solar as well and wind and we
need to export a lot of our good
American technology for them in a number
of ways clean air issues and and others
I think they can benefit from what we've
learned Hey
a little bit of good news today folks
you had a lot of bad news here's some
good news from 1970 to date when I
started this we have four times of cars
in LA millions more people now here
comes the good news we have a fraction
of the smog yeah because we did it we
did that you and I and everybody here in
LA did that David because of catalytic
converters on cars combined cycle gas
turbines spray paint booze all the
things big and small cleaning up the
ports of San Pedro and Long Beach you
know plugging those boats in instead of
having running in the harbor all that
stuff big and small that we did all
worked so we need to export that great
technology to China and India and have
them use it in to clean up the air in
these cities and have them be better
world stewards you know for climate
change yeah I like that you're bringing
these all around to something actually
positive which you barely ever hear when
we talk about these environmental issues
anyway what do you think let us know in
the comments right now
you